My name is Ioannis Ikonomou.
I'm from Greece and I speak 32 languages.
Russian, Portuguese, Norwegian, Turkish, Hungarian, Czech, Polish...
Ioannis is what we call a "hyperpolyglot."
It means he can speak a lot of languages.
By the time I was 20, I'd already learned some 15 languages...
...and when I moved to Brussels and started my career at the EU institutions,...
...I added more official EU languages.
This doesn't happen by just sitting at home and studying them.
I speak to my husband in Polish because he is Polish.
I dream in all kinds of languages.
Wait wait, before we go, if anyone knows it's you,...
...what is the most complicated language to learn?
Mandarin.
Mystery solved.